[Music]
aoc
was literally handing out turkeys in ted
cruz's neighborhood bro
and it was a brilliant so political move
yeah because is she doing it to kind of
like grift off the situation
sure but everybody's okay with grifting
if there are people benefiting from yes
for example if you're a rich person and
you give a lot of money to charity
nobody cares that you're writing it off
in taxes because there are so many
people that are
taking advantage of that charitable
donation yeah so she raised millions of
dollars she's leaning into this
but she's basically digging cruz's grave
right now
every million it goes up that grave gets
a foot deeper
it's over for that moment brilliant but
keep in mind remember she said ted cruz
she blamed him
for what happened to her yeah she was
like ted cruz reminds me of
uh like the guy who sexually assaulted
me do you guys remember that
she said a few of the senators who were
inciting she felt like were inciting the
riots
and then telling people to get over it
she was like that reminds me of the
guy who assaulted me or when i was
younger and just telling me to get over
these things do you guys remember what
i'm talking about
i thought i don't know the full
clarified yeah well she also
uh she blamed cruz and other folks for
allowing her to be exposed to
potentially getting murdered but then
she
like clapped back at him when he agreed
to her tweet about
the congressional uh look into gamestop
and all of that and she like brought it
back again like oh
uh i don't care that you agree with me
you almost had me murdered
right right right right right that was a
point where like yeah
so this is a personal vendetta but this
is a savvy political champion
with that she's a star she a [ __ ]
star just
savvy dude she's [ __ ] sad she's not
dumb
she's not dumb she knows what she's
doing and she's it's even not even
beyond the ted cruz thing is the biggest
thing but also it's a red state where
they're going to be inclined to hate her
but as somebody whose parents are stuck
yo god bless her you're the best you can
flip people like that yeah
nobody in texas yeah the easiest way to
get people on your side is to give them
money
yes it's not even andrew yang went from
nowhere
right like who the [ __ ] is andrew yang
right asian dude
out of nowhere becomes a presidential
candidate just by saying i want to give
everybody a thousand dollars
literally all he goes i want to give
every i believe in universal basic
income if you're like i don't know what
the [ __ ] that is
you want a thousand dollars well yeah
this [ __ ] chinese guy is smart
this guy's genius i love this chinese
yang gang yeah oh my god
remember yeah gang gang yeah where i'm
at
oh he listen do you know a single policy
of his outside if i want to give
everybody a thousand
absolutely not automation he knows is
bad i'm with that
and he's smart he probably knows a bunch
of [ __ ] maybe he was a businessman i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
he's running for mayor new york
everybody in new york is like i think i
like this guy not because he's walking
in bodegas and grabbing a [ __ ] fruit
salad
he's gonna give everybody a thousand
dollars even if he hasn't said that
everybody in new york is like
oh yeah the [ __ ] is gonna give us a
thousand dollars we got to vote for that
guy
if you give people money they like you
yup very simple
yup and this chick aoc is out there
handing out duckets
in ted cruz's backyard it's unbelievable
it's actually better than turkeys like
if instead of turkeys you were just
handing people hundred dollar bills
don't you think they'd like them a lot
of boston market
save 80 bucks live a great life what
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
what poor person got a big enough oven
to fit a 20-pound turkey
nobody's just a frozen turkey that down
the next block they're trying to sell
they're flipping turkeys yup dude
anyway so she's a [ __ ] savvy chick
this girl
she's a star and ted cruz is getting
cocked up king cuck
getting cucked out in your own state by
your biggest political rival that's so
true
oh my god this guy's just watching her
give out money and then he's like here
you want some shitty bottled water
you can't even get my [ __ ] essentia
that's right he was getting the water
with the salt in it he was giving the
publix brand
yeah you give him publix water out there
bro so
the cr the trade the crazy [ __ ] about uh
aoc also or maybe this is the thing with
ted cruz is like
he's completely devoid of uh excuse me
understanding social interaction so he
could be like uh
on the spectrum a bit yeah like he
understands how to play the character of
a human being like any time you
see him talking you're like oh he's
playing a character of a human being
yeah you know it's like almost like a
comic that like has like a fake voice
you're like oh there's a funny character
you're playing but it's not really you
yes
right um will ferrell is great at this
now
so if if you look at him through that
lens
he can be smart and completely devoid of
any rationale
as to how this could uh affect him
negatively yeah he's just looking at
like a robot he's like
well if i move out of my house and go to
a hotel how's that different than if i
move out of my house and go to cancun
yeah like they have internet in cancun
they have internet in my hotel here
i can't meet with people because of
kovid
so what's the difference i can get my
work done in a hotel in cancun or
i can get my work done in the hotel in
downtown dallas wherever the [ __ ] he
lives yeah
right i mean i i can see how an autistic
person or a spectrum person
would go through that logic and go yeah
it's not that bad
i just think he's a coward but i could
fair
if he wasn't a coward he wouldn't go
if he was a coward he'd be so terrified
cowards live in fear right they live in
fear of public perception they live in
terror and fear of being actually
physically harmed he would
be fearful of the physical harm or
emotion
it doesn't occur to him that part but
he's also like i'm
or so socially stupid he's also like i'm
cold i don't want to be cold i'm not
standing here for this i'm getting the
[ __ ] out right
that's some coward cowardly [ __ ] yeah
i guess what i'm trying to say you know
why we want him to stay because misery
loves company my parents are miserable
[ __ ] you miserable yeah you the
senator
you miss it dude i'm petty bro patrice
said the best [ __ ] about bush he goes i
love bush
and then they were like why he goes
there he goes this is after the 9 11
[ __ ] he goes he goes he goes
because his whole [ __ ] is if we if we
die everybody dies
and that's lit if we gonna die everybody
gonna die yeah